the grid the narration um bom bom
bom-bom Tron roll it cycles Pyrenees
disk battles fun spectacular arenas and
cycles that raced on ribbons of light
well spectacular was 1982 computer and
backlit animation would laugh and I
called him hmm
well avatar you created an avatar also
this exposition works perfectly as a
bedtime story because it's guaranteed to
put us all to sleep that'll have to
learn the next time you're good with
waiting twenty years right always on the
same team whoa creepy CG unification
alert I guess even bridges can't span
the uncanny valley and come CEO and
video game icon Kevin Flynn has
disappeared good grief is this entire
movie exposition not even five minutes
in and we follow a full minute of
bedtime story with another full two
minutes of television ghosts graveyard
news broadcasts to jam even more
knowledge into your brain space he was
best known for designing frog and space
paranoids the two best-selling video
games in history clearly coolspot
did not exist in this universe the
future of end time will most likely
depend on what becomes of this now
orphaned little boy now orphaned
seriously
I know news reporters can be harsh but
Jesus and it's not he's Annie living the
hard-knock life he's sitting on a
fortune and probably being spoiled by
his grandparents also income has a board
of directors who can make all the hard
decisions over the years it takes young
Sam to grow into Country Strong this
isn't the first company who's lost at
CEO and had to function in this way
didn't this movie see Batman Begins
luckily for Sam and the camera operator
these cars are perfectly spaced for Sam
to bob and weave his motorcycle through
is it too soon to take a cent off for
this incredible Daft Punk score cuz
sweet dad this is good stuff now that is
a big door indeed and if the entrance to
the tower is worth protecting with that
big a door shouldn't there also be video
surveillance this works so only the
third floor had a camera in the stairs
where's the logic in that also I don't
care if Sam's been hitting Planet
Fitness for years there's no way he's
still going that fast after 60 flights
of stairs and jeans a leather jacket and
wearing a parachute backpack sure comes
as no surprise who we had to thank a man
whose fathers own notable history with
income helped make this company what it
is today
Edward Dillinger actually this should
come as a huge surprise when Flynn went
AWOL I'm sure they had to scramble and
get some new blood in to make sure the
company didn't flounder but they got
back in bed with a Dillinger family
daddy Dillinger was the guy who only had
his job because he ripped off Flynn and
then almost brought the company down
with this MC people there weren't any
capable software engineers available
that didn't have such shady connections
also movie we see perfectly good Killian
Murphy by not making him the bad guy or
even having him in the rest of the movie
given the prices that we charge to
students fan this dude discount Michael
Douglas's so hard that I had to look
that up to confirm it's not him OS 12 is
the most secure operating system ever
released the idea of sharing our
software or giving it away for free
disappeared with Kevin Flynn man we're
able to squeeze a massive amount of
condescending dickish Ness into one
scene where are you gonna write through
now hey you don't want to do that
especially considering you were right
when you said he had nowhere to run the
security guards balance beam routine is
not only unlikely and unsafe it's
completely unnecessary
what kind of psychopath is driving this
taxi if someone lands on your vehicle
for any reason who speeds up and drives
like a bat out of hell
also this might take place in 2010 but
it sure as hell feels like it's using
cab drivers from 1982
your message to the board was very
clever yeah this actually seems
plausible considering the dog is smart
enough to unwrap the burger before
eating it instead of digging right in
even though this area of town is super
rundown and abandoned all these years
later you're gonna tell me that no one
ever sold or looted these arcade
machines and they still work both movies
tell us that these are the best and most
sophisticated computer systems ever but
they can't immediately tell the
difference between a user and a program
digital upskirting what's up with the
weather in the grid I realize we have to
be darkened downward but the sane LA and
Blade Runner it's a completely digital
fabrication and has no need for storms
why are these Fembots just staring and
waiting is there a line in their code
that programs for maximum creepiness man
sure was nice of Sam's opponent to wait
attack until after Sam was able to see
that expositional delecia they're polite
but firm in this universe what reason is
given that Sam is so goddamn good at
video games at least 1982 Tron had a
scene where Flynn beats the high score
on a game all we've seen Sam do is some
computer hacking BASE jumping and
motorcycle hijinks Inc the scene no
matter how cool it may be it's
definitely not earned Sam is a disc to
glass floors I feel like I just got
downtime why do I feel like Sam wouldn't
last two goddamn seconds in this game
considering he's not only an experienced
in it he's never been in the fucking
grid at all
the Curious Case of Benjamin bridges
what do you do same thing I'm going to
do to you
that's racist what exactly is this crowd
is there an upper and lower middle class
in the grid that scrounges to gather
enough cash to finally take the family
to the big game is tailgating involved I
mean that's the movie I'd rather see
excellent words sir the crowd seemed
quiet energized it wasn't meant for them
it was obviously meant for the movie
audience because this movie is much more
interested in boring exposition than
actual droning now this second deal
because he rides a motorcycle in the
real world we saw him hop one goddamn
interstate ramp earlier not competing to
death race involving toxic chemicals but
don't actually discuss the plan
just nod split off and hope for the best
aya Sam still holding on to this light
cycle baton if his now D resolved friend
had already grabbed it shouldn't have
let go
or was he planning on dragging him
around by the arm how did Sam get his
disk back clewd took it from him back at
the control room did Ron just hand that
back over to him and who needs to
upgrade to some better grid security
how did cor even get near here yeah but
you could easily answer that one like
just saying to meet someone would
probably be sufficient dinner soon we'll
talk then you can make actual food here
how's that possible why is that possible
- spectacular how the hell did they
adjourn to the sing room not only
mid-story but practically mid-sentence
the possibilities of their route code
their digital DNA disease history
science philosophy the screenwriters are
clearly feeding Jeff ridges random
dictionary words to see which ones he
can make sound most lebowski in bio
digital jazz man nice try dude but
people don't even know what regular jazz
is so your presentations falling on deaf
ears the ISOs we're gonna be my gift to
the world and movies back to expositor
again I swear there's more this movie
told us exposition then actually shown
as part of the story so what happened
clue in the foyer with a candlestick I
tried to get back but I couldn't get to
the portal it uses massive power and it
can't stay open forever
it can only be open from the outside
that seems like pretty important
knowledge maybe you share it with at
least one other person on the outside
like Alan so you never get trapped in
your own system with my disk it's
possible and then one game over the guy
doesn't dig imperfection but how even
though he's got a bunch of minions lined
up now is he for sure we're gonna take
over the world it's a decent army but
it's not even the size of like the NYPD
helmet
brought you here through the grid um
Disney's prime directive is to cash in
on every last drop of nostalgia juice I
said it was clue clue set that page
that's why you're here
the more they try and use this page as
the inciting incident the less sense it
makes
how did clue even have Allen's number to
get a call-out to the pager how did clue
know Allen and or Sam would even
investigate or figure out how to get in
the game
how did clue even know what a pager is
am I good stone yeah that you don't want
to be stuck in this place for eternity
either that's quite a good instinct
considering wyldstyle here hasn't even
spoken once yet about what she wants or
who she even is he's basing this leap
solely because she loves jewels burn if
there's one thing that movies have
taught us it's that when introspection
time comes they're sure to be a nearby
mirror
this is his sector and no other
information man I hope there's a foxy
character that has somehow I met Sam
earlier today that'll guide him to the
right place also there's so much in this
movie that's only partially explained
like there are discs on their back that
are apparently both weapon and ID chips
but what exactly do they do all I know
is that it made Sam's eyes flash blue
when he put it on about a half hour ago
and he hasn't even asked anyone why
since look I know we need to get
everyone in place for the finale but
Holi does this movie throw the shoots on
any momentum it had during the second
act movie prompts the sudden realization
that I never wanted to have sex with
multiple simulated programs until just
now and what a couple punks
the son of innumerable possibilities he
has to walk into mine why does everyone
know Sam exists it Flynn's biggest
concern and reason he's still here is
because he didn't want clue getting out
then why would he give away any
knowledge of his business or familial
ties in the outside world also what
purpose did Castro serve in the original
game was it like Grand Theft Auto where
instead of playing with disks or light
cycles you could just pick up hookers
and casters club libations libations and
for everybody vibrations are
specifically drinks for deity and gods
maybe I could see why they would look at
Sam in this light but whomever the
equivalent of casters norm is can just
stick to the cold Coors Light thank you
y'all host between this Twilight and
passengers it's clear Michael Sheen
could make a good living just stealing
the thought of middling sci-fi movies
that star pretty people thank you my
name is Johnny you know what's truly
outrageous Jim that despite being told
how dangerous the grid is Flynn jr. just
keeps trusting every program he comes in
contact with main antagonist and his
posse systematic
position to look more badass when
appearing on the scene cliche okay who
made the decision for trying to be
turned into a growling man beast
what did clue even do to him to make
this happen King Jarvis metal apples the
go-to fruit of digital assholes grid
why'd you our clue I am clue you will
create the perfect system I will create
the perfect system
bing-bang-boom also no wonder this
didn't work out well Lin yadda yadda
through the important worse than John
Hammond after the Pudge I needed to
reinvent myself I guess all the Uncle
Sam creepy skeleton and neon horror
masks were taken so castor Zeus went for
an Alpina look but we're not here to
relive the past
oh my dear Zeus that's unfortunately
exactly why we're here and you'll need
to forge this not easy these days if you
say so discount albino matrix twin the
truth is we know so little about how
those discs work it's almost like
nonsense anyway so Agent Orange crashes
through the roof and everyone panics but
the DJ's are just like oh we totally
have a group for this if the staff does
the job why waste time on kicks and
punches
well suck my desk you son of a glitches
what Flynn should have set in the
version of this movie where they
realized they had already gone so far
off the rails that they might as well
embrace it they use latex Makana why is
Flint sanity here just now stepping into
this fight and using whatever these God
powers are he rode with Cora right if he
can neo this matrix that hard why not
lead with it so what do we do now we do
nothing we do it your way
full-on sprint to the portal well that
escalated quickly
would be clue there we have a chance but
why didn't clue leave for the portal the
second that he got Flynn's disc why does
he have to make a rousing speech gah
this is still technically a game right
aren't there rules this is
well good thing whatever the this is was
sitting right there ready to take off
movie is doing a terrible job of helping
us understand why getting to the portal
is such an insurmountable task she said
I saw the last I saw all right and I so
of course that would explain this much
younger female live-in companion much
better than what's been creeping me out
for the last hour of this movie now it's
time for you to tell me a story
dammit Flynn no enough story time this
movie has more stories than the building
formerly known as the Sears Tower ice
caps are melting war in the Middle East
Laker Celtics back no mention of Robert
Pattinson and Kristen Stewart making it
official the beginning stages of one
direction or the Lady Gaga meat dress
why is Sam leaving out all the important
events should have seen this place back
then couldn't wait to show it to you man
I thought Flynn couldn't sound any more
like a nostalgic hippie but apparently I
was wrong I'm gonna head home for one
more day with you
Jesus Flynn's character Arcas flimsier
than a sheet of digital saran wrap wait
is that the chrome logo on Zeus's
forehead I mean bar owners do have to
open multiple tabs so I guess it makes
sense you had the drink
how did chrome-dome not see this
double-cross coming and more importantly
why is he just standing here when it's
obvious this building's about to blow up
the Sun yeah I've never had to describe
it before wha radiant beautiful and one
of the few things that could wake you up
after Garrett Hedlund vocal cadence put
you to sleep oh just another unnecessary
plot device that pans the run time
seriously this needs a harsh fucking
editor it's got cool ideas great music
and excellent visuals can't get out of
its own weight I've seen what users are
capable of glue
you don't belong with them what exactly
are users capable of doing playing
Uncharted for 72 hours straight while
ingesting Ho Hos and dr. pepper but it's
closing up soon right so maybe you cut
the speech a little short or just mix it
all together he's taken all this with
him these figures out how to do it yes
because the disk thing is in the
stand-up thing and the glowy lights are
moving and there's orange stripes and
stuff every single light in this area is
glowing orange except for the one our
hero happens to need for camouflage so
that worked out nicely I'm not a program
my name is Sam flan really movie has
been nothing but more philosophizing and
story exposition for the last 25 minutes
but the second the action is about to
get good you pull the cut to the
surprise guy in the other room hearing
it happen routine not cool man not cool
at all totally so I'm taking this
vehicle you were not authorized Jedi
mind-trick has certainly evolved over
the years China honest you're gonna need
it sure clue is coming after these
assholes with a literal army and the
portal may close at any moment they
still definitely have time for what
passes is witty banter in this movie
nice sure but couldn't she have just
flown over did he just give a subtle
hand signal to another moving jet from
50 yards away I got a hand signal for
your movie but it's not exactly as
subtle as that one so you've got a
hotshot kid in the rear gunner chair in
a space battle I think what you mean to
say is I've got a bad feeling about this
Tron
come I've been asking myself the same
question for the last hour and 47
minutes miss Hoover it's all in our
dream Sam you know dreams awesome I
guess we'll never know what the hell
happened to this poor bastard even
though his character is the namesake of
the franchise that is take it down hang
on ruff I guess every landing scene is
required to include this dialogue even
though Korra has never flown this ship
before or landed anywhere near the port
exactly they saw Tron take out clue ship
so how would he have gotten here well
maybe for 2010 but Flynn should try
watching this movie now as if it didn't
borrow from a galaxy far far away enough
she has an actual lightsaber
this twist is remarkable for being
extremely obvious and somehow at the
same time completely incomprehensible
since when can you wear someone else's
disc
can someone please do an explainer on
how this technology works oh and you
were right about what I'm behind
everything no seriously what exactly was
he right about we've been gridlocked for
about two hours here and honestly can't
remember what he said to you what's next
Sam I guess we're supposed to change the
world
how does Corps exist in the physical
world where did her body come from can
someone help me understand the mystery
of Olivia Wilde's body come on I want to
show you something tell me he doesn't
mean his strong
[Laughter]
the grid a digital frontier dance my
stereo BioDigital jazz man you're like
jazz what can I get for you what you
look like a whiskey man okay we're in
trouble we're not supposed to be here
well I won't tell if you don't
game over game over man you or clue
I am clue you will create the perfect
system I will create the perfect system
energy theft is not a joke Jim millions
of families suffer every year Michael
Michael
[Music]